Britain's first, and so far only, female prime minister deserved her nickname, the "Iron Lady".
Margaret Thatcher was a formidable politician at home and abroad...
...and her 11-and-a-half year premiership changed the face of Britain.
Her tough economic reforms and brand of individualistic capitalism...
...would come to be known as "Thatcherism", ensuring her place in the history books.
However, her divisive legacy has as many detractors as fans.
The greengrocer's daughter and former chemist became Conservative Party leader in 1975...
...and prime minister four years later.
Her popularity and uncompromising reputation grew after a tough military response...
...to Argentina's invasion of the British Falkland Islands in 1982.
The rest of that decade would be defined by the Thatcher government's...
...restructuring of the industrial and social fabric of Britain.
She crushed a miners' strike and took on the trade unions, reigning in their strength.
Her policies saw a decline in traditional manufacturing...
...and created a decade synonymous with unashamed moneymaking.
Unemployment and social deprivation were also rife under Thatcher.